ANNOUNCER: Open content is
provided under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu .
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: OK.
I finished up last time
talking about lists.
And I pointed out that lists are
mutable, showed you some
examples of mutation.
We can look at it here; we
looked at append, which added
things to lists, we looked at
delete, deleting things from a
list. You can also assign to a
list, or to an element of a
list. So ivy sub 1, for example,
could be assigned
minus 15, and that will actually
mutate the list.
So heretofore, when we wrote
assignment, what we always
meant, was changing the binding
of a variable to a
different object.
Here, we are overloading the
notation to say, no, no, ivys
is still bound to the same
object, but an element of ivys
is bound to a different
object.
If you think about it, that
makes sense, because when we
have a list, what a list is,
is a sequence of objects.
And what this says is, is the
object named by the expression
ivys sub 1, is now bound to the
object, if you will, named
by the constant minus 15.
So we can watch this run here.
Idle can-- that's exciting.
I hadn't expected that answer.
All right, your question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] four
elements to ivys, and you tell
it to change the fifth element
of ivys to negative 15, will
it add it or [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: Well,
I'll tell you how ol-- let's
answer that the easy way.
We'll start up a shell
and we'll try it.
All right, we'll just get out
of what we were doing here.
And so, we now have some things,
so we, for example,
have ivys, I can print ivys
, and it's only got three
elements but your question
probably is just as good for
adding the fourth as adding
the fifth, so what would
happen if we say ivys sub 3--
because that of course is the
fourth element, right?
Let's find out.
OK.
Because what that does is, it's
changing the binding of
the name ivys, in this
case, sub 1.
What it looked at here, with the
name ivys sub 3, and said
that name doesn't-- isn't
bound, right?
That isn't there.
So it couldn't do it, so instead
that's what append is
for, is to stick things on to
the end of the list. But a
very good question.
So we can see what we did here,
and, but of course I can
now, if I choose, say something
like, ivys sub 1 is
assigned minus 15, and now if
I print ivys, there it is.
And again, this points out
something I wanted to me--
I mentioned last time, list can
be heterogeneous, in the
sense that the elements can be
multiple different types.
As you see here, some of the
elements are strings and some
of the elements are integers.
Let's look at another example.
Let's suppose, we'll start
with the list,
I'll call it l 1.
This, by the way, is a really
bad thing I just did.
What was-- what's really bad
about calling a list l 1?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: Is it l
1, or is it 11, or is it l l?
It's a bad habit to get into
when you write programs, so I
never use lowercase L except
when I'm spelling the word
where it's obvious, because
otherwise I get all sorts of
crazy things going on.
All right, so let's make
it the list 123.
All right?
Now, I'll say L 2 equals L 1.
Now I'll print L 2.
Kind of what you'd guess, but
here's the interesting
question: if I say L 1 is
assigned 0, L 1 sub 0 is
assigned 4, I'll print L 1.
That's what you expect, but
what's going to happen
if I print L 2?
423 as well, and that's because
what happened is I had
this model, which we looked at
last time, where I had the
list L 1, which was bound to
an object, and then the
assignment L 2 gets L 1, bound
the name L 2 to the same
object, so when I mutated this
object, which I reached
through the name L 1 to make
that 4, since this name was
bound to the same object, when
I print it, I got 423.
So that's the key thing to--
to realize; that what the
assignment did was
have two separate
paths to the same object.
So I could get to that object
either through this path or
through that path, it didn't
matter which path I use to
modify it, I would see it when
I looked at the other.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: So the
question, if I said a is
assigned 2, b is assigned a,
and then a is assigned 3.
Is that your question?
So the question is, a is
assigned 1, b is assigned a, a
is assigned 2, and then if
I print b, I'll get 1.
Because these are not mutable,
this is going to be assigned
to an object in the store, so
we'll draw the picture over
here, that we had initially a
is bound to an object with 1
in it, and then b got bound to
the same object, but then when
I did the assignment, what that
did was it broke this
connection, and now had a
assigned to a different
object, with the number,
in this case, 2 in it.
Whereas the list assignment you
see here did not rebind
the object l 1, it
changed this.
OK?
Now formally I could have had
this pointing off to another
object containing 4, but that
just seemed excessive, right?
But you see the difference.
Great question, and a very
important thing to understand,
and that's why I'm belaboring
this point, since this is
where people tend to get pretty
confused, and this is
why mutation is very important
to understand.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG:
I'm just assuming
it'll be a great question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG:
Exactly.
So if-- very good question-- so,
for example, we can just
do it here.
The question was, suppose I now
type L 1 equals the empty
list. I can print L 1, and I can
print L 2, because again,
that's analogous to this
example, where I just swung
the binding of the identifier.
So this is important, it's a
little bit subtle, but if you
don't really understand this
deeply, you'll find yourself
getting confused a lot.
All right?
OK.
Let me move on, and I want to
talk about one more type.
By the way, if you look at the
handout from last time, you'll
see that there's some other
examples of mutation,
including a function
that does mutation.
It's kind of interesting, but I
don't think we need-- think
we've probably done
enough here that I
hope it now make sense.
That one type I want to talk
about still is dictionaries.
Like lists, dictionaries are
mutable, like lists, they can
be heterogeneous, but unlike
lists, they're not ordered.
The elements in them don't
have an order, and
furthermore, we have generalized
the indexing.
So lists and strings, we can
only get at elements by
numbers, by integers, really.
Here what we use is, think
of every element of the
dictionary as a key value pair,
where the keys are used
as the indices.
So we can have an example,
let's look at it.
So, if you look at the function
show dics here,
you'll see I've declared a
variable called e to f, ah,
think of that as English to
French, and I've defined a
dictionary to do translations.
And so, we see that the string
one corresponds the-- the key
one corresponds to the value un
the key soccer corresponds
to the French word football,
et cetera.
It's kind of bizarre, but the
French call soccer football.
And then I can index in it.
So if I print e to f of soccer,
it will print the
string football.
So you can imagine that this is
a very powerful mechanism.
So let's look what happens
when I run--
start to run this.
All right.
So, it says not defined-- and
why did it say not defined,
there's an interesting
question.
Let's just make sure we get this
right, and we start the
show up again--
All right, so, I run
it, and sure
enough, it shows football.
What happens if I
go e to f of 0?
I get a key error.
Because, remember, these
things are not ordered.
There is no 0th element.
0 is not a key of this
particular object.
Now I could have made 0 a key,
keys don't have to be strings,
but as it happened, I didn't.
So let's comment that out, so
we don't get stuck again.
Where we were before, I've
printed it here, you might be
a little surprised
of the order.
Why is soccer first?
Because the order of this
doesn't matter.
That's why it's using
set braces, so
don't worry about that.
The next thing I'm doing is--
so that's that, and then--
I'm now going to create another
one, n to s, for
numbers to strings, where my
keys are numbers, in this case
the number 1 corresponds
to the word one, and
interestingly enough, I'm also
going to have the word one
corresponding to the number 1.
I can use anything I want for
keys, I can use anything I
want for values.
And now if we look at this,
we see, I can get this.
All right.
So these are extremely
valuable.
I can do lots of things with
these, and you'll see that as
we get to future assignments,
we'll make heavy use of
dictionaries.
Yeah.
Question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: You can,
but you don't know what
order you'll get them in.
What you can do is you can
iterate keys, which gives you
the keys in the dictionary, and
then you can choose them,
but there's no guarantee
in the order in
which you get keys.
Now you might wonder, why
do we have dictionaries?
It would be pretty easy to
implement them with lists,
because you could have a list
where each element of the list
was a key value pair, and if
I wanted to find the value
corresponding to a key, I could
say for e in the list,
if the first element of e is the
key, then I get the value,
otherwise I look at the next
element in the list.
So adding dictionaries, as
Professor Grimson said with so
many other things, doesn't
give you any more
computational power.
It gives you a lot of expressive
convenience, you
can write the programs much
more cleanly, but most
importantly, it's fast.
Because if you did what I
suggested with the list, the
time to look up the key would be
linear in the length of the
list. You'd have to look
at each element until
you found the key.
Dictionaries are implemented
using a magic technique called
hashing, which we'll look at a
little bit later in the term,
which allows us to retrieve
keys in constant time.
So it doesn't matter how big
the dictionary is, you can
instantaneously retrieve the
value associated with the key.
Extremely powerful.
Not in the next problems set but
in the problem set after
that, we'll be exploiting that
facility of dictionaries.
All right.
Any questions about this?
If not, I will turn the podium
over to Professor Grimson.
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON:
I've stolen it.
This is like tag team
wrestling, right?
Professor Guttag has you
on the ropes, I get
to finish you off.
Try this again.
OK.
We wanted to finish up that
section, we're now going to
start on a new section, and I
want to try and do one and a
half things in the
remaining time.
I'm going to introduce one topic
that we're going to deal
with fairly quickly, and then
we tackle the second topic,
it's going to start today, and
we're going to carry on.
So let me tell the two
things I want to do.
I want to talk a little bit
about how you use the things
we've been building in terms
of functions to help you
structure and organize
your code.
It's a valuable tool that you
want to have as a programmer.
And then we're going to turn to
the question of efficiency.
How do we measure efficiency
of algorithms?
Which is going to be a really
important thing that we want
to deal with, and we'll start
it today, it's undoubtedly
going to take us a couple more
lectures to finish it off.
Right, so how do you
use the idea of
functions to organize code?
We've been doing it implicitly,
ever since we
introduced functions.
I want to make it a little more
explicit, and I want to
show you a tool for
doing that.
And I think the easy way
to do is-- is to
do it with an example.
So let's take a really
simple example.
I want to compute the
length of the
hypotenuse of a right triangle.
And yeah, I know you know how
to do it, but let's think
about what might happen if
I wanted to do that.
And in particular, if I think
about that problem-- actually
I want to do this-- if I think
about that problem, I'm going
to write a little piece
of pseudo code.
Just to think about how I would
break that problem up.
Pseudo code.
Now, you're all linguistic
majors, pseudo means false,
this sounds like code that ain't
going to run, and that's
not the intent of the term.
When I say pseudo code, what I
mean is, I'm going to write a
description of the steps,
but not in a particular
programming language.
I'm going to simply write
a description of what
do I want to do.
So if I were to solve this
problem, here's the way I
would do it.
I would say, first thing I want
to do, is I want to input
a value for the base
as a float.
Need to get the base in.
Second thing I want to do, I
need to get the height, so I'm
going to input a value for the
height, also as a float, a
floating point.
OK.
I get the two values in, what
do I need to do, well, you
sort of know that, right?
I want to then do, I need to
find the square root-- b
squared plus h squared, right?
The base plus the height, that's
the thing I want for
the hypotenuse-- and I'm going
to save that as a float in
hyp, for hypotenuse.
And then finally I need to print
something out, using the
value in hyp.
OK.
Whoop-dee-doo, right?
Come on.
We know how to do this.
But notice what I did.
First of all, I've used the
notion of modularity.
I've listed a sequence of
modules, the things that I
want to do.
Second thing to notice, is that
little piece of pseudo
code is telling me things
about values.
I need to have a float.
I need to have another float
here, it's giving me some
information.
Third thing to notice is,
there's a flow of control.
The order which these things
are going to happen.
And the fourth thing to notice
is, I've used abstraction.
I've said nothing about how I'm
going to make square root.
I'm using it as an abstraction,
saying I'm going
to have square root from
somewhere, maybe I'll build it
myself, maybe somebody gives it
to me as part of a library,
so I'm burying the details
inside of it.
I know this is a simple example,
but when you mature
as a programmer, one of the
first things you should do
when you sit down to tackle
some problem is write
something like this
pseudo code.
I know Professor Guttag
does it all the time.
I know, for a lot of
you, it's like, OK,
I got a heavy problem.
Let's see, def Foobar open
paren, a bunch of parameters.
Wrong way to start.
Start by thinking about what
are the sequences.
This also, by the way, in some
sense, gives me the beginnings
of my comments for what
the structure of my
code is going to be.
OK.
If we do that, if you look at
the handout then, I can now
start implementing this.
I wanted to show you that, so,
first thing I'm going to do is
say, all right, I know I'm going
to need square root in
here, so I'm going to,
in fact, import math.
That's a little different from
other import statements.
This says I'm going to get the
entire math library and bring
it in so I can use it.
And then, what's the first
thing I wanted to do?
I need to get a value
for base as a float.
Well OK, and that sounds like
I'm going to need to do input
of something, you can see that
statement there, it's-- got
the wrong glasses on
but right there--
I'm going to do an input with
a little message, and I'm
going to store it in base.
But here's where I'm going to
practice a little bit of
defensive programming.
I can't rely on Professor Guttag
if I give this-- if
this code to him, I can't rely
on him to type in a float.
Actually I can, because he's a
smart guy, but in general, I
can't rely on the user--
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: I
wouldn't do it right
to see if you did.
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON:
Actually,
he's right, you know.
He would not do it, just to
see if I'm doing it right.
I can't rely on the user.
I want to make sure I
get a float in it,
so how do I do that?
Well, here's one nice
little trick.
First of all, having read in
that value, I can check to
see, is it of the right type?
Now, this is not the nicest way
to do it but it'll work.
I can look at the type of the
value of base and compare it
to the type of an actual float
and see, are they the same?
Is this a real or a float?
If it is, I'm done.
How do I go back if it isn't?
Well, I'm going to create
a little infinite loop.
Not normally a good idea.
I set up a variable here,
called input OK.
Initially it's false, because
I have no input.
And then I run a loop in which
I read something in, I check
to see if it's the right type,
if it is, I change that
variable to say it's now the
correct type, which means the
next time through the loop, I'm
going to say I'm all set
and I'm going to bounce out.
But if it is not, it's going
to print out a message here
saying, you screwed up, somewhat
politely, and it's
going to go back around.
So it'll just cycle until
I get something
of the right type.
Nice way of doing it.
Right, what's the second
thing I do?
Well, I get the same sort of
thing to read in the height,
once I have that I'm going to
take base squared plus height
squared, and there's a form
that we've just seen once
before, and it's going to repeat
it, that is math.SQRT
and it says the following: it
says, take from the math
library the function
called sqrt.
OK.
We're going to come back to this
when we get to objects,
it's basically picking up that
object and it's applying that,
putting that value into hype,
and then just printing
something out.
And again, if I just run this,
just to show that it's going
to do the right thing, it says
enter base, I'm obnoxious, it
says oops, wasn't a float, so
we'll be nice about it, and I
enter a height, and it prints
out what I expected.
I just concatenated those
strings together, by the way,
at the end.
All right.
Notice what I did.
OK.
I went from this description,
it gives me [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
some information.
I need to have a particular
type.
I made sure I had the
particular type.
I've used some abstraction to
suppress some details here.
Now if you look at that list,
there is actually something I
didn't seem to check, which is,
I said I wanted a float
stored in hyp.
How do I know I've got
a float in hyp?
Well I'm relying on the
contract, if you like, that
the manufacturer of square root
put together, which is,
if I know I'm giving it two
floats, which I do because I
make sure they're floats, the
contract, if you like, of
square root says I'll give
you back a float.
So I can guarantee I've got
something of the right type.
OK.
I know this is boring
as whatever.
But there's an important
point here.
Having now used this pseudo code
to line things up, I can
start putting some additional
structure on this.
And in particular, I'm sure
you're looking at this going--
will look at it if we look
at the right piece--
going, wait a minute.
This chunk of code and this
chunk of code, they're really
doing the same thing.
And this is something
I want to use.
If I look at those two pieces
of computation, I can see a
pattern there.
It's an obvious pattern
of what I'm doing.
And in particular, I can then
ask the following question,
which is, what's different
between those
two pieces of code?
And I suggest two
things, right?
One is, what's the thing
I print out when
I ask for the input?
The second thing is, what do I
print out if I actually don't
get the right input in?
And so the only two differences
are, right there,
and there versus
here and here.
So this is a good place to
think about, OK, let me
capture that.
Let me write a function, in fact
the literal thing I would
do is to say, identify the
things that change, give each
of them a variable name because
I want to refer to
them, and then write a function
that captures the
rest of that computation
just with those
variable names inside.
And in fact, if you look down--
and I'm just going to
highlight this portion, I'm not
going to run it-- but if
you look down here, that's
exactly what that does.
I happen to have it commented
out, right?
What does it do?
It has height, it says, I've got
two names of things: the
request message and
the error message.
The body of that function
looks exactly like the
computation up above, except
I'm simply using those in
place of the specific message
I had before.
And then the only other
difference is obviously, it's
a function I need to
return a value.
So when I'm done, I'm going to
give the value back out.
All right?
And that then let's me get
to, basically, this code.
Having done that, I simply call
base with get float, I
call height with get float, and
do the rest of the work.
All right.
What's the point
of doing this?
Well, notice again.
What have I done?
I've captured a module
inside of a function.
And even though it's a simple
little thing here, there's
some a couple of really nice
advantages to this.
All right?
First one is there's
less code to read.
It's easier to debug.
I don't have as much
to deal with.
But the more important thing
is, I've now separated out
implementation from
functionality, or
implementation from use.
What does that mean?
It means anybody using that
little function get float
doesn't have to worry about
what's inside of it.
So for example, I decide I want
to change the message I
print out, I don't have to
change the function, I just
pass in a different parameter.
Well if I-- you know, with
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE sorry,
let me say it differently.
I don't need to worry about
how checking is done, it's
handled inside of
that function.
If I decide there's a better
way to get input, and there
is, then I can make it to change
what I don't have to
change the code that
uses the input.
So, if you like, I've built a
separation between the user
and the implementer.
And that's exactly one of the
reasons why I want to have the
functions, because I've
separated those out.
Another way of saying it is,
anything that uses get float
doesn't care what the details
are inside or shouldn't, and
if I change that definition, I
don't have to change anything
elsewhere in my code, whereas if
I just have the raw code in
there, I have to go
off and do it.
Right, so the things we want
you to take away from this
are, get into the habit of using
pseudo code when you sit
down to start a problem, write
out what are the steps.
I will tell you that a good
programmer, at least in my
mind, may actually go back and
modify the pseudo code as they
realize they're missing things,
but it's easier to do
that when you're looking at a
simple set of steps, than when
you're in the middle
of a pile of code.
And get into the habit of using
it to help you define
what is the flow of control.
What are the basic modules, what
information needs to be
passed between those
modules in order to
make the code work.
OK.
That was the short topic.
I will come back to this some
more and you're going to get
lots of practice with this.
What I want to do is
to start talking
about a different topic.
Which is efficiency.
And this is going to sound
like a weird topic, we're
going to see why it's of
value in a second.
I want to talk about efficiency,
and we're going
to, or at least I'm going to, at
times also refer to this as
orders of growth, for reasons
that you'll see over the next
few minutes.
Now, efficiency is obviously
an important consideration
when you're designing code,
although I have to admit, at
least for me, I usually want
to at least start initially
with code that works, and then
worry about how I might go
back and come up with more
efficient implementation.
I like to have something I
can rely on, but it is an
important issue.
And our goal over the next
couple of lectures, is
basically to give you
a sense of this.
So we're not going to turn
you into an expert on
computational efficiency.
That's, there are whole courses
on that, there's some
great courses here on that,
it takes some mathematical
sophistication, we're going to
push that off a little bit.
But what we-- what we do want
to do, is to give you some
intuition about how to
approach questions of
efficiency.
We want you to have a sense of
why some programs complete
almost before you're
done typing it.
Some programs run overnight.
Some programs won't stop
until I'm old and gray.
Some programs won't stop until
you're old and gray.
And these are really different
efficiencies, and we want to
give you a sense of how do you
reason about those different
kinds of programs.
And part of it is we want you
to learn how to have a
catalog, if you like, of
different classes of
algorithms, so that when you get
a problem, you try and map
it into an appropriate class,
and use the leverage, if you
like, of that class
of algorithms. Now.
It's a quick sidebar, I've got
to say, I'm sure talking about
efficiency to folks like you
probably seems really strange.
I mean, you grew up in an age
when computers were blazingly
fast, and have tons of memory,
so why in the world do you
care about efficiency?
Some of us were not so lucky.
So I'll admit, my first computer
I program was a PDP6,
only Professor Guttag even knows
what PDP stands for, it
was made by Digital Equipment
Company, which does not exist
anymore, is now long gone.
It had, I know, this is
old guy stories, but
it had 160k of memory.
Yeah.
160k.
160 kilobits of memory.
I mean, your flash cards have
more than that, right?
It had a processor speed
of one megahertz.
It did a million operations
per second.
So let's think about it.
This sucker, what's
it got in there?
That Air Mac, it's, see, it's
got, its go-- my Air Mac, I
don't know about John's, his is
probably better, mine has
1.8 gigahertz speed.
That's 1800 times faster.
But the real one that blows me
away is, it has 2 gig of
memory inside of it.
That's 12 thousand times
more memory.
Oh, and by the way?
The PDP6, it was in a rack
about this tall.
From the floor, not
from the table.
All right, so you didn't grow
up in the late 1800s like I
did, you don't have to
worry about this
sort of stuff, right?
But a point I'm trying to make
is, it sounds like anymore
computers have gotten so
blazingly fast, why should you
worry about it?
Let me give you one other
anecdote that I can't resist.
This is the kind of thing you
can use at cocktail parties to
impress your friends
from Harvard.
OK.
Imagine I have a little lamp, a
little goose-- one of those
little gooseneck lamps, I'd put
it on the table here, I'd
put the height about a f-- about
a foot off the table.
And if I was really good, I
could hit, or time it so that
when I hurt-- yeah, try again.
When I turn this on switch on
in the lamp, at exactly the
same time, I'm going to hit a
key on my computer and start
it running.
OK.
In the length of time it takes
for the light to get from that
bulb to the table, this
machine processes two
operations.
Oh come on, that's amazing.
Two operations.
You know, you can do the
simple numbers, right?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
Light travels basically a
foot in a nanosecond.
Simple rule of thumb.
Now, the nanosecond is what,
10 to the minus 9 seconds.
This thing does 2 gig
worth of operations.
A gig is 10 to the 9, so it
does two operations in the
length of time it takes light
to get from one foot off the
table down to the table.
That's amazing.
So why in the world do you
care about efficiency?
Well the problem is that the
problems grow faster than the
computers speed up.
I'll give you two examples.
I happen to work in
medical imaging.
Actually, so does Professor
Guttag.
In my in my area of research,
it's common for us to want to
process about 100 images a
second in order to get real
time display.
Each image has about a million
elements in it.
I've got to process about a half
a gig of data a second in
order to get anything
out of it.
Second example.
Maybe one that'll hit a little
more home to you.
I'm sure you all use Google, I'm
sure it's a verb in your
vocabulary, right?
Now, Google processes--
ten million?
Ten billion pages?
John?
I think ten billion was the
last number I heard.
Does that sound about right?
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG:
I think it might
actually be more by now.
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON:
Maybe more by now.
But let's, for the sake of
argument, ten billion pages.
Imagine you want to search
through Google to find a
particular page.
You want to do it in a second.
And you're going to just do it
the brute force way, assuming
you could even reach all of
those pages in that time.
Well, if you're going to do
that, you've got to be able to
find what you're looking for
in a page in two steps.
Where a step is a comparison
or an arithmetic operation.
Ain't going to happen, right?
You just can't do it.
So again, part of the point here
is that things grow-- or
to rephrase it, interesting
things grow at
an incredible rate.
And as a consequence, brute
force methods are typically
not going to work.
OK.
So that then leads to the
question about what should we
do about this?
And probably the obvious thing
you'll think about is, we'll
come up with a clever
algorithm.
And I want to disabuse
you of that notion.
It's a great idea if
you can do it,
The guy who--
I think I'm going to say this
right, John, right?
Sanjay?
Ghemawat?-- with a guy who was
a graduate of our department,
who is the heart and soul behind
Google's really fast
search, is an incredibly smart
guy, and he did come up with a
really clever algorithm about
how you structure that search,
in order to make it happen.
And he probably made a lot
of money along the way.
So if you have a great idea,
you know, talk to a good
patent attorney and get
it locked away.
But in general, it's hard
to come up with the
really clever algorithm.
What you're much better at doing
is saying how do I take
the problem I've got and map it
into a class of algorithms
about which I know and use the
efficiencies of those to try
and figure out how
to make it work.
So what we want to do, is, I
guess another way of saying it
is, efficiency is really about
choice of algorithm.
And we want to help you learn
how to map a problem into a
class of algorithms of
some efficiency.
That's our goal.
OK.
So to do this, we need a little
more abstract way of
talking about efficiency, and
so, the question is, how do we
think about efficiency?
Typically there's two things
we want to measure.
Space and time.
Sounds like an astrophysics
course, right?
Now, space usually we--
ach, try it again.
When we talk about space, what
we usually refer to is, how
much computer memory does it
take to complete a computation
of a particular size?
So let me write that down, it's
how much memory do I need
to complete a computation.
And by that, I mean, not how
much memory do I need to store
the size of the input, it's
really how much internal
memory do I use up as I go
through the computation?
I've got some internal variables
I have to store,
what kinds of things do I
have to keep track of?
You're going to see the
arguments about space if you
take some of the courses that
follow on, and again, some
nice courses about that.
For this course, we're
not going to worry
about space that much.
What we're really going
to focus on is time.
OK.
So we're going to focus here.
And the obvious question I
could start with is, and
suppose I ask you, how long does
the algorithm implemented
by this program take to run?
How might I answer
that question?
Any thoughts?
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON:
Ah, you're jumping
ahead of me, great.
The answer was, find a
mathematical expression
depending on the number
of inputs.
It was exactly where
I want to go.
Thank you.
I was hoping for a simpler
answer, which is, just run it.
Which is, yeah I know,
seems like a dumb
thing to say, right?
One of the things you could
imagine is just try it on and
input, see how long it takes.
You're all cleverer than that,
but I want to point out why
that's not a great idea.
First of all, that depends on
which input I've picked.
All right?
Obviously the algorithm is
likely to depend on the size
of the input, so this
is not a great idea.
Second one is, it depends on
which machine I'm running on.
If I'm using a PDP6, it's going
to take a whole lot
longer than if I'm
using an Air Mac.
All right?
Third one is, it may depend
on which version
of Python I'm running.
Depends on how clever the
implementer of Python was.
Fourth one is, it may depend on
which programming language
I'm doing it in.
So I could do it empirically,
but I don't want to do that
typically, it's just not a
great way to get at it.
And so in fact, what we
want is exactly what
the young lady said.
I'm going to ask the following
question, which is-- let me
write it down-- what is the
number of the basic steps
needed as a function
of the input size?
That's the question we're going
to try and address.
If we can do this, this is good,
because first of all, it
removes any questions about what
machine I'm running on,
it's talking about
fundamentally, how hard is
this problem, and the second
thing is, it is going to do it
specifically in terms
of the input.
Which is one of the things
that I was worried about.
OK.
So to do this, we're going to
have to do a couple of things.
All right, the first one is,
what do we mean by input size?
And unfortunately, this depends
on the problem.
It could be what's the size of
the integer I pass in as an
argument, if that's what
I'm passing in.
It could be, how long is the
list, if I'm processing a list
or a tuple It could
be, how many bits
are there in something.
So it-- that is something where
we have to simply be
clear about specifying what
we're using as input size.
And we want to characterize it
mathematically as some number,
or some variable rather, the
length of the list, the size
of the integer, would be the
thing we'd want to do.
Second thing we've got
to worry about is,
what's a basic step?
All right, if I bury a whole lot
of computation inside of
something, I can say, wow, this
program, you know, runs
in one step.
Unfortunately, that one step
calls the Oracle at Delphi and
gets an answer back.
Maybe not quite what you want.
We're typically going to use
as basic steps the built-in
primitives that a machine
comes with.
Or another way of saying it is,
we're going to use as the
basic steps, those operations
that run in constant time, so
arithmetic operations.
Comparisons.
Memory access, and in fact one
of the things we're going to
do here, is we're going to
assume a particular model,
called a random access model,
which basically says, we're
going to assume that the length
of time it takes me to
get to any location in
memory is constant.
It's not true, by the way, of
all programming languages.
In fact, Professor Guttag
already talked about that, in
some languages lists take
a time linear with the
length to get to it.
So we're to assume we can get
to any piece of data, any
instruction in constant time,
and the second assumption
we're going to make is that the
basic primitive steps take
constant time, same amount
of time to compute.
Again, not completely true,
but it's a good model, so
arithmetic operations,
comparisons, things of that
sort, we're all going to assume
are basically in that
in that particular model.
OK.
Having done that, then, there
are three things that we're
going to look at.
As I said, what we want to do
is, we want to count the
number of basic steps it takes
to compute a computation as a
function of input size.
And the question is, what
do we want to count?
Now, one possibility
is to do best case.
Over all possible inputs to
this function, what's the
fastest it runs?
The fewest, so the minimum,
if you like.
It's nice, but not particularly
helpful.
The other obvious one to
do would be worst case.
Again, over all possible inputs
to this function,
what's the most number of
steps it takes to do the
computation?
And the third possibility, is
to do the expected case.
The average.
I'm going to think
of it that way.
In general, people focus
on worst case.
For a couple of reasons.
In some ways, this would be
nicer, do expected cases, it's
going to tell you on average how
much you expect to take,
but it tends to be hard to
compute, because to compute
that, you have to know a
distribution on input.
How likely are all the inputs,
are they all equally likely,
or are they going to depend
on other things?
And that may depend on the
user, so you can't
kind of get at that.
We're, as a consequence, going
to focus on worst case.
This is handy for a
couple of reasons.
One, it means there
are no surprises.
All right?
If you run it, you have a sense
of the upper bound,
about how much time it's going
to take to do this
computation, so you're not
going to get surprised by
something showing up.
The second one is, a lot of the
time, the worst case is
the one that happens.
Professor Guttag used an example
of looking in the
dictionary for something.
Now, imagine that dictionary
actually has something that's
a linear search to go through
it, as opposed to the hashing
he did, so it's a list,
for example.
If it's in there, you'll find
it perhaps very quickly.
If it's not there, you've got
to go through everything to
say it's not there.
And so the worst case often
is the one that shows up,
especially in things
like search.
So, as a consequence, we're
going to stick with the worst
case analysis.
Now, I've got two
minutes left.
I was going to start showing
you some examples, but I
think, rather than doing that,
I'm going to stop here, I'm
going to give you two minutes
back of time, but I want to
just point out to you that we
are going to have fun next
week, because I'm going to show
you what in the world
that has to do with
efficiency.
So with that, we'll
see you next time.